We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you type the word courthouse into a Google image search, you get hundreds of results that look really similar to the US Supreme Court building. Big steps, a granite Corinthian colonnade, topped by a grand pediment. If the architecture could talk, it would say respect me.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州和全球各地进行合作与创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。如果你在谷歌图片搜索中输入“法院”这个词，你会得到数百个看起来与美国最高法院大楼非常相似的结果。巨大的台阶，花岗岩科林斯柱廊，顶部是一个宏伟的山墙。如果建筑会说话，它会说：尊重我。
Serious S happens here. That's Brett Myers. He's reporting this week's show. He went to the New York County Family Court in Lower Manhattan. It's a building that looks nothing like the classic Roman and Greek inspired architecture that most of us associate with courthouses. There's little to equate family with the building beyond dysfunction. If the family court could have talked before its 2006 renovation, it would have said, all who enter are doomed. Built in 1975, this polished black cubus hulk is about as welcoming as the death star.
这里发生着严肃的事情。那是布雷特·迈尔斯。他正在报道本周的节目。他去了位于曼哈顿下城的纽约县家庭法院。那栋建筑看起来一点也不像我们大多数人与法院联系在一起的经典罗马和希腊风格建筑。除了功能失调之外，几乎没有什么能将家庭与这座建筑联系起来。如果家庭法院在2006年翻新之前会说话，它会说：所有进入这里的人都注定要失败。这座建于1975年的黑色抛光立方体建筑，其欢迎程度堪比死星。
That's Eugene Patron, reading from an article he wrote about his time as a paralegal in the building. He sums up the most common argument about the original design. The New York County Family Court at 60 Lafayette Street is infamous in architecture circles as an example of form giving not a damn about function. And that's an easy argument to make. Absolutely. It filled me with rage the first time I saw this building back in the late 90s. The design just seemed so wrong for a family courthouse.
那是尤金·帕特隆在朗读他写的一篇文章，关于他在那栋大楼里担任律师助理的时光。他总结了关于最初设计最常见的论点。位于拉斐特街60号的纽约县家庭法院在建筑界臭名昭著，是一个形式完全不顾功能的例子。这是一个很容易提出的论点。绝对是。90年代末我第一次看到这栋建筑时，它让我感到愤怒。对于一个家庭法院来说，这种设计看起来太不合适了。
It was like hiring Dick Cheney to be the nanny for your kids. It was brutalist, think repetitive angles and thick heavy forms and lots and lots of concrete. It's a pretty polarizing style, which I actually kind of like. And before the 2006 remodel, it was possible to appreciate this building, but from a far. Up close was a different story. The shiny black granite panels that covered the whole thing were falling off and threatening
这就像雇佣迪克·切尼来做你孩子的保姆。它是粗野主义风格，想想重复的角度、厚重的形式以及大量的混凝土。这是一种非常两极分化的风格，我其实还挺喜欢的。在2006年改造之前，人们还可以从远处欣赏这栋建筑，但近看又是另一回事了。覆盖整个建筑的闪亮黑色花岗岩板正在脱落，并威胁着
to kill people on the ground. It was a looming and menacing building. Even the entrance was scary. There were these huge pylons offset at 45 degree angles, so that when you entered the building, you could actually see what it was you were walking into. It was like stepping into a black hole. Definitely very bleak and very, oh my god, what is this, a black building, you know, is this a courthouse? Miriam Hernandez works there as an interpreter translator. It didn't really have the feeling of humanity or humane, you know, it didn't really have that. What kind of stuff happens inside? Oh my God, the question should be what doesn't happen.
要砸死地面上的人。这是一栋阴森恐怖的建筑。甚至入口都很吓人。那里有一些巨大的塔架以45度角偏移，所以当你进入大楼时，你实际上可以看到你正走进什么地方。就像走进了一个黑洞。绝对非常凄凉，非常，天哪，这是什么，一栋黑色的建筑，你知道，这是法院吗？米里亚姆·埃尔南德斯在那里担任口译员。它真的没有那种人性化或人道的感觉，你知道，它真的没有。里面发生了什么样的事情？天哪，问题应该是，什么没有发生。
What doesn't happen? I mean, it's like you could write maybe a forever book about what takes place inside, you know? And that forever book wouldn't be a light read. You would have chapters about custody battles and divorces and abuse. Children going into family court and their fates of being decided behind those doors. If anything, you would hope that the architecture would inspire trust, not fear, and maybe even convey
什么没有发生？我的意思是，你可以写一本关于里面发生的事情的永恒之书，你知道吗？而那本永恒之书不会是一本轻松的读物。你会有关于监护权争夺、离婚和虐待的章节。孩子们走进家庭法院，他们的命运在那些门后被决定。如果说有什么的话，你希望建筑能激发信任，而不是恐惧，甚至可能传达
a little bit of warmth. But instead, court employees referred to it as the Darth Vader building. Luke, your mother and I are getting the divorce. Pardon me, Lord. The question is, was the form of the New York County family courthouse completely antithetical to its function? I met a guy who's got a really interesting theory about this. This guy goes by the name Loftur I. My Clark Kent is a basic guy
一点温暖。但相反，法院员工称它为“达斯·维达大楼”。卢克，你母亲和我正在离婚。抱歉，大人。问题是，纽约县家庭法院的形式是否完全与其功能背道而驰？我遇到了一个对这个理论有非常有趣见解的人。这家伙叫洛夫图尔·I。我的克拉克·肯特是一个普通人
to freelance research. By day he's a writer researcher for a real estate blog, but his secret identity is Loftar 1. It's the handle he uses when contributing to Wired New York, this hugely popular website about all things New York City. The community section is basically a forum for urban design geeks and laughter one is one of the biggest geeks on the site So how many posts have you posted since June? Wait too many for a sane person about A couple thousand. I'm not sure now. It's like 28,000 something like that. It's 28,131 posts. That's as of when
从事自由研究。白天他是房地产博客的撰稿人和研究员，但他的秘密身份是Loftar 1。这是他在为Wired New York投稿时使用的网名，这是一个关于纽约市所有事物的超级热门网站。社区版块基本上是城市设计极客的论坛，而Loftar 1是该网站上最大的极客之一。那么你从六月以来发了多少帖子？等等，对于一个正常人来说太多了，大约几千个。我现在不确定了。大概是28,000左右。是28,131个帖子。那是截止到什么时候
28,131 posts. I checked this morning, did you? You've had it a few today? In fact, he averages almost 13 posts per day, and most are related to architecture and urban planning. One of his first posts was about the remodel of the building we're talking about, the family courthouse, the building we're standing in front of. That old place, I felt like I was kneeling down and crawling through a teeny little hole in a cave. And I didn't know what the hell, there was a bear, there were bats, there was something on the other side.
28,131个帖子。我今天早上查的，你查了吗？你今天发了几个？事实上，他平均每天发近13个帖子，大部分与建筑和城市规划有关。他最早的帖子之一是关于我们正在谈论的这栋建筑的改造，即家庭法院，我们正站在它面前的这栋建筑。那个老地方，我觉得自己像是在跪着爬过洞穴里一个小小的洞。我不知道到底是什么，有一只熊，有蝙蝠，对面有什么东西。
What happened inside was not going to be good. They should have put a, you know, abandoned hope all you who enter here, because that's what the message was sending. In laughter, one argues that that message had a timestamp. That old, black, shiny, desktop of a building reflected the New York of the times, the New York back in the 70s when it was built. Watergate, financial distress, social divide, it all makes total sense. Total sense that this building looked the way it did, and this argument gains even more
里面发生的事情不会是什么好事。他们应该放一个“进入此地者，放弃一切希望”，因为这就是它传达的信息。洛夫图尔·I认为那个信息有一个时间戳。那栋黑色、闪亮、像桌面一样的建筑反映了那个时代的纽约，即70年代建造它时的纽约。水门事件、金融危机、社会分歧，这一切都完全说得通。这栋建筑看起来是这样完全说得通，而且这个论点获得了更多
weight when you consider a 1977 story by Fame New York Times reporter Lori Johnston. The article profiles users of the court and what is essentially a critique of the system. She interviews people who spend days shuffling from one waiting room to another. And their critiques of the bureaucracy go hand in hand with critiques of the architecture. Here's a quote from the 1977 article. It seems like a maze to this place, or worse.
分量，当你考虑到著名《纽约时报》记者洛里·约翰斯顿1977年的一篇报道时。这篇文章介绍了法院的用户，本质上是对该系统的批评。她采访了那些花几天时间从一个候审室走到另一个候审室的人。他们对官僚机构的批评与对建筑的批评如出一辙。这是1977年文章中的一段引语。这个地方看起来像个迷宫，或者更糟。
It seems like it's run like a prison with uniforms all over. Maybe it's meant to discourage you from going ahead. It's like, oh, you want form to meet function. This is how this court functions. This is what this court does. It sucks people in and spits them out and there's no feeling. It doesn't solve the problems. Now of course, the courthouse has been remodeled and it's warmer and friendlier and it reflects a city that's friendlier and more functional.
它看起来像是一个由穿着制服的人管理的监狱。也许它是为了阻止你继续前进。就像，哦，你想要形式满足功能。这就是这个法院运作的方式。这就是这个法院所做的。它把人吸进去又吐出来，没有任何感觉。它没有解决问题。当然，现在法院已经改造过了，它更温暖、更友好，反映了一个更友好、功能更完善的城市。
The black facade is all gone, it's kind of a light gray now. The entrance is all opened up, it even has kind of an awning. That doesn't look imposing or unfriendly at all. And there's no more threat that those black granite panels are going to fall off the side of the building and kill people. You know, yeah, it's also kind of boring. The remodel is definitely a little boring, and it's not a building I want to talk to my friends about, but that original building angered me, and it was something I talked to my friends about.
黑色的外墙全都不见了，现在是一种浅灰色。入口完全打开了，甚至还有一种遮阳篷。看起来一点也不威严或不友好。而且那些黑色花岗岩板再也不会有从大楼侧面掉下来砸死人的威胁了。你知道，是的，它也挺无聊的。改造绝对有点无聊，它不是我想和朋友谈论的建筑，但原来的那栋建筑让我生气，那是我会和朋友谈论的事情。
It was dark and interesting. And now Brett kind of misses the old building. But I also know that I'm privileged because I don't have to interact with it, because I don't have to work there, and I'm not a kid who has to walk into family court. For them, this MilkyBland remodel is a definite improvement. And probably a sacrifice worth making. Come on, it's for kids, man. 99% invisible was produced this week by Brett Myers and me Roman Mars, with support from
它黑暗而有趣。现在布雷特有点怀念那栋旧建筑了。但我也知道我享有特权，因为我不必与它互动，因为我不必在那里工作，而且我不是必须走进家庭法院的孩子。对他们来说，这种平淡无奇的改造绝对是一种进步。而且可能是一个值得做出的牺牲。得了吧，这是为了孩子，伙计。《99%隐形》本周由布雷特·迈尔斯和我罗曼·马尔斯制作，并得到了
Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW local public radio 91.7 in San Francisco. The American Institute of Architects in San Francisco, in the center for architecture and design. You can find out more at the website. It's 99%izzable.org you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Lunar的支持，用创造力创造不同。这是旧金山KALW当地公共广播电台91.7的一个项目。旧金山美国建筑师协会，在建筑与设计中心。你可以在网站上了解更多信息。网址是 99%invisible.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。